théâtre avec les salons la pièce que
joue actuellement madeleine renaud
théâtre du rond point avec une
particularité puisque elle est dirigée
par son propre fils jean pierre grand
val et salons mike les routiers
il ya tout d'un coup de moment j'ai
besoin de moments et puis à tout d'un
coup j'ai besoin de madeleine a donc ça
barde est à l'étude elle est allée et
puis j'ai besoin de mon bac j'ai besoin
de sa tendresse où ça à rennes yeux ou
ses conseils sa wii
me paraissait tantôt tels que je
voudrais que vous puissiez
tantôt tels que je crains qu'on ne
m'ait jamais peut-être tels que vous
nous travaillons depuis tellement
longtemps ensemble ils jouent à
madeleine tellement travaillé j'ai vu
tellement travaillé que pour moi décale
est en répétition si je puis dire c'est
vraiment de madeleine et non pas moment
c'est tout à fait terminée à ce moment
là et comme madeleine est une
d'une simplicité et qu'elle écoute tous
qu'elle fait tous cas métal ans elle lui
demande que ce soit moi ou claude régy
ou duras ou ou lavelli ou bob wilson il
n'y a aucune différence et elle est
d'une souplesse est extraordinaire et là
il n'y a plus du tout de lien familiaux
aucun ya heureusement sur terre
quelqu'un il vous prend par un
personnage de comics
qui n'ayant pas de masquer mais
va bien
est ce que c'était un enfant sage
si c'était c'était un enfant sage oui
c'était mon concert je crois tout de
même supportable
est ce que m avait été très bien en
scène madeleine quand j'étais petit
c'est une mère qui n'était très bien en
selle comment comment ça se passait
parce que finalement vous avez toujours
vécu dans mon nom vous est né dans le
théâtre mais je suis ni joie à la
comédie française
je suis dans la comédie française et
madeleine jouer encore les derniers
jours et on l'a vite transporté de sa
loge au palais-royal karl habitait juste
là et le monstre état est arrivé à moi
après la coupe alors commencé à jouer
agnès quand vous viviez dans les mêmes
lieux comme moi
je devine est ce que vous savez
vous pensiez ce que je savais et nous ne
savions pas nous
ce temps on passe
mieux si quand ils reviennent
j'avais une image de l'enfance j'engage
manger une image si vous me forcer à la
voir mais je n'aime pas le passer je
fais tu as there is efface facilement et
je ferai tout pour l'effacer je n'aime
que le présence avant tout est un tout
petit peu l'avenir